[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen ziel ist es
die etwa zeit ist ja schon längst da und
ich möchte natürlich was mit erdbeeren
zu bereiten erst hatte ich überlegt so
süße kleine cache am netz aber auf die
habe ich jetzt heute noch keine lust
deswegen gibt heute erst per pudding
schnecken mit rhabarber schweiz grad mit
der mutter auf dem wochenmarkt da haben
auch frische erdbeeren frischen
rhabarber bekommen und das wird heute
jetzt zu leckeren erdbeeren schmecken
zubereitet ich denke ich mache später
einfach aus dem rhabarber so eine art
rabatt pudding oder rhabarber kompott
schauen wir gleich mal erst mal gibt's
denn basic den ganz traditionellen grund
teig für käfig dafür verwende ich einen
würfel hefe 80 gramm zucker 2 esslöffel
warmes wasser 500 gramm mehl da könnt
ihr weizen oder dinkel nehmen ein etwas
vanille extrakt einen teelöffel salz
etwa 250 gramm milch und 120 gramm
butter weist jetzt die zubereitung ganz
einfach hefe zucker und wasser in eine
rührschüssel verrühren ihr könnt jetzt
entweder eine küchenmaschine nehmen oder
ihn verwendet einfach eure hände und
chinesin teig durch dann gebt ihr da das
mehl ach nee das motto tradition auf
[Musik]
dann gibt er jetzt als mehl dazu
und ein ei
ich gucke manchmal wenn ich zum beispiel
nutzt macht dann macht es oft auch
mittlerweile so dass ich dann zwei
eigelb in den teig geben und die zwei
weiß dann in die füllung manchmal im
gebrochen und in den teig man sagt
nämlich ganz auf das eiweiß land ein
bisschen austrocknet aber ich finde bei
so einem teig das später sowieso so
fruchtig und frisch gefüllt wird da
macht es gar nichts aus also mache ich
jetzt hier einfach nein dann etwas von
links
[Musik]
dann gebe ich jetzt die milch dazu
und salz und butter immer zum schluss
weil nämlich die hefe fett und salz
nicht so sehr mag deswegen am anfang
immer erst mit wasser und zucker in
verbindung bringen und das war ganz zu
schließen und geht aber nicht besser auf
dann wieder richtig richtig schön
und jetzt ist wichtig ist etwa acht bis
zehn minuten lang verkneten endet er mit
den händen oder einfach mit der
küchenmaschine
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr hier gerne
auch schon hitze dazu geben es ist 30 32
und ich gehe schon mal der rhabarber
waschen
ich habe ziehe den rhabarber gewaschen
und schädeln und dafür nehmt ihr euch
einfach ein messer in die hand geht hier
oben dran und zieht diese fäden außen
wecken und so könnt ihr ihn wirklich
ganz ganz einfach stehlen es gibt auch
rhabarber sorten da kann man die schale
mit verzehren aber gerade der der außen
rot ist und innen grün da würde ich die
schale einfach entfernen das ist auch so
eine etwas säuerliches orte und die
passt echt perfekt denn dann hat man so
einen neuerlichen ausgleich
da ich jetzt meine erdbeeren und den
rhabarber bricht jetzt schon genial der
hefeteig ist jetzt auch so weit so sieht
doch super
hervorragend und jetzt vorm ich den
einfach kurz zu einer schönen kugel und
fette ihnen damit er nicht austrocknet
dann darf der aufgehen bis aufs doppelte
entweder hier in der kenwood oder bei
raumtemperatur abgedeckt oder bei der
stufe im backofen
mache ich einfach immer gern back
transport drauf
und
dann zeige ich hier mal die restlichen
zutaten ich habe zehn nämlich 400 gramm
gestellten rhabarber
250 gramm zucker 45 g speisestärke einen
teelöffel vanille extrakt und etwas
zitronensaft dann nehmt euch am besten
gleich einen topf und der rabatt da ist
es jetzt am besten ich zucker den und
lasst ihn einfach ein bisschen stehen
damit das wasser verliert und dann ist
es an dicken also dass pudding machen so
ein bisschen einfacher das heißt jetzt
einfach den rhabarber in feine stücke
schlägen
die beste kombi ist immer rhabarber
erdbeer vanille das ist immer
dann kommt noch ein bisschen
zitronensaft dazu und wenn die zitrone
hinten so eine spitze hat dann schneide
ich die einfach weg dann geht es nämlich
mit der trickboxx klasse einfacher und
gibt mir einfach so ein bisschen
zitronensaft dazu gar nicht so viel
dabei ist nämlich schon sauer dann gibt
jetzt hier noch direkt in zucker drauf
und die stärke
und aufwand extrakt
jetzt ein bisschen verrühren dann
verbindet sich alles mit dem zucker und
dann lasse ich es erstmal so für etwa 30
minuten stehen wenn es länger steht ist
auch nicht schlimm hauptsache der zucker
bringt den rhabarber und dienten dazu
dass die reben die feuchtigkeit
verlieren und dann kann ich später ganz
einfach zu einem pudding aufkochen das
heißt jetzt erstmal die arbeit getan der
hefeteig geht auf das kann hier stehen
bleiben und ich werde in der
zwischenzeit mit murat einen podcast
aufnehmen denn jeden donnerstag läuft
bei uns auf jeder plattform ein podcast
und das mache ich jetzt dürft ihr gerne
mal reinhören falls er denn noch nicht
kennt
und
dann geht es gleich weiter nach der
podcast pause
es hat sich hier die flüssigkeit
angesammelt wie ihr sehen könnt und
jetzt kann ich den pudding ganz normal
aufkochen das obst und der rhabarber des
zerfällt so ein bisschen und dann
einfach so etwas 23 minuten köcheln
lassen und das passt dann schon
[Musik]
der hefeteig ist aufgegangen podcast ist
aufgenommen die
rabatt beim masters abgekühlt jetzt
mache ich noch eine zweite creme damit
einfach so so einen cremigen faktor noch
bekommt dafür nehmen die 250 gramm quark
ihr könnt aber auch kein mascarpone
nehmen 30 gramm stärke 40 gramm
puderzucker ein ei und ein bisschen
zitronen abrieb und jetzt gibt dir
einfach alles in eine schüssel und
verrät die zutaten
da gibts
da gibt es kein richtig oder falsch
einfach alles irgendwie rührschüssel und
verrühren und zitrone wirklich nur ein
bisschen okay da gibt's ein falsch wenn
ihr zu viel nimmt dann ist es ja nicht
zuzutrauen wir wollen nur so einen so
ein hauch von zitrone im april
den hefeteig schön ausrollen
ich liebe hefeteig
und am besten nehmt ihr euch jetzt eine
große offene form entweder im mai form
oder gusseisen form oder keramik form
glasform was auch immer ihr möchtet im
mai ist supereinfach zum putzen
gusseisen ist auch hervorragend diese
keramik formen sind aus super also nicht
echt was sehr gerne möchte
irgendwas schönes ich finde sowas ist
das auge match und wenn man so ein
normales offenberg nimmt ist okay für
den geschmack aber soviel die optik
finde ich immer was dekoratives schön
jetzt zu einem schönen großen rechteck
ausrollen
dann kommt jetzt erst mal die creme
drauf
und dann kommt jetzt die rabatte drauf
mit den erdbeeren man sieht jetzt auch
ganz gut dies schon fest das heißt es
wird dann nicht so wie sage ich da nicht
so durchmessern
die farbe stamme
dann dürft ihr das ganze jetzt auf
rollen ich wollte das jetzt mal so rum
dann hätte ich jetzt hier meine ofen
form und ihr dürft jetzt entscheiden wie
groß die schnecken sein sollen meine
rolle ist tatsächlich richtig geworden
aber ich finds gut und ihr könnt jetzt
entweder dicke schneiden dann sind sie
höher oder die bühne dann sind sie
flacher und er bekommt mehr da
entscheidet er am besten so wie eure
ofen form eben auch ist ich will das
ganze jetzt so ein bisschen in die höhe
wächst
statt in die breite so wie man sich beim
menschen oft wünscht
dass sie groß werden und ich bereit
und da nehme ich jetzt für fahrten
schneit von außen nach innen denn so
drückt ihr die schnecken nicht zusammen
wie mit einem messer sondern er quetscht
sie quasi zusammen und dann wird sie
eben trotzdem schön rund und
dann einfach in die form reinsetzen aber
ich schneide jetzt erstmal bis
sieht richtig richtig schön aus was sich
generell bei solchen zimtschnecken immer
mache entweder verstecke ich das ende so
unten dass man es nicht sieht oder ich
nehme dir an stücke und die packe ich
jetzt hier einfach rein in so eine
kleine form dann ist es nämlich nicht
verschwendet und ich habe aber trotzdem
ich hier einfach die perfekte schöne
form das ganze kommt jetzt in den kalten
backofen dann schalte ich den ofen 1 auf
175 grad ober unterhitze wenn ihr
möchtet gerne mit dampf stoß dann gehen
sie noch mal richtig extrem gut auf und
dann dürfen sie jetzt erst mal darin
backen für ungefähr 35 bis 40 minuten
ihr müsst ja immer so ein bisschen euren
backofen beobachten und während der
backofen quasi aufheizt geht der
hefeteig nochmal gut auf das heißt ich
muss ihnen jetzt einfach nicht noch mal
gehen lassen ich finde es immer so ein
bisschen zeit sparen deswegen kommt es
jetzt kalten ofen dann den ofen an
machen und später gibt's dann noch von
einer klausur drauf das packt natürlich
nicht so lange das bak so ungefähr 15
bis 20 minuten und immer schön euren
ofen kontrollieren weil viele ofen
backen einfach unterschiedlich und meine
angaben sind immer so etwa angaben wie
es eben bei mir backt und wenn ihr den
gleichen open hat wie ich dann passt
ansonsten passt eben vielleicht nicht ob
ich freue mich jetzt drauf
so sehen jetzt die rubber etwa schnecke
aus richtig gut da kommt jetzt noch
nicht los wird drauf für die glasur
nämlich 100 gramm erdbeeren etwa 40
gramm frischkäse 100 gramm butter zucker
vanille extrakt und zitrone und frische
erdbeeren zum dekorieren es gibt hier
einfach die erdbeeren in einen mixer
oder er macht es einfach nur für ihr
stop das geht auch in
der geburtshöhle
[Musik]
und da gebe ich jetzt auch die anderen
zutaten rein muss sagen dass ich diese
gewürzmühle echt gerne mag vor allem
wenn ich so kleine mengen glasuren
machen möchte oder salat dressing zb
weil da einfach alles so schnell vermixt
wird oder so eine kleine menge
puderzucker selber herstellen aus
normalem haushaltszucker oder nüsse
malen aber eben kleine menge dann
braucht man nicht immer gleich so einen
riesen mixa dafür mit dem zucker gucke
jetzt tatsächlich mal wenn die edgar
nämlich schon recht süßen nämlich nicht
alles also das schmecke ich jetzt gleich
nach geschmack und
[Musik]
so mein leben macht ihr seid also wenn
richtig schön
ok allein schon für die dik flüssigkeit
brauche ich doch einen
extrakt
und nur ein spritzer zitronensaft
ich meine klar so zu flüssig
ich bin ja auch normal mache ich 100
gramm puderzucker unser zwei esslöffel
zitronensaft und habe ich 100 gramm
erdbeeren
das machte klar so noch mal
mit weniger erdbeeren und daraus machen
wir später so
milchshakes daraus machen wenn eis
schröder ist ein joghurt ein oder es ist
ein eis
das finde ich jetzt super spar
und schmeckt gut die genaue rezeptur
schreibe ich hier noch nirgendwo ich
habe ein bisschen experimentiert und das
lässt hier so drüber laufen dann kommen
noch ein paar frische erdbeeren drauf
und dann möglich fertig noch probiert
werden
kaum zwei
gleich zwei und hier zum programm
ja und
ja ich habe erdbeer rhabarber schnecken
gebacken ich liebe
[Gelächter]
ja ja ich esse halte aber nicht
die schnecken
[Gelächter]
ich habe keine
schnecken no way
sorry aber schnecken bei mir neulich
hatte ich hab mir mal ich
hatte ich hatte im biologieunterricht
habe ich mit meiner freundin jana und
anna damals mit beiden zwar meine besten
freundinnen in der 56 und so weiter und
dann haben wir im biounterricht einen
film gemacht über schnecken und
praktisch so schnecken daheim bei mir
auf dem balkon und gezüchtet in seinem
wir heißen so ein ding jutta terrarium
und dann hatte war hat nur so
salatblätter dann haben sie eine
glasscheibe wie die da so hoch wandern
weist hat sich hoch schlängeln
ja ich habe echt zum mini waren zudem
wurden sie immer größer
richtig süß machen
doch später aber noch im film gemacht
über einen wald die vier jahreszeiten im
wald und dann
wird auch so sein dass video gelöscht
und wir hatten halt so ein jahr den wald
gefilmt und dann war so okay was machen
wir jetzt bei werten frühjahr sommer
herbst winter und dann haben wir einfach
alles nachgefragt
folgt die reportage von tieto und dann
haben wir so im sommer kurz vor abgabe
dieses films haben wir dann einfach so
ich mache es dann schon gesehen aber wir
haben so getan als wird keiner sehen und
so schaal sind so angezogen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wer so die hawaii ist doch alles grün
geht da hinten da gibt kein grün
nicht so ich weiß sogar noch wo das war
in in hambrücken im vogelpark und
soonwald dran und da haben wir das dann
so nachgestellt bei den wildschweinen
ich stamme brauchen kein bestehen
eigentlich sprechen ist man immer mit
der hand
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
durchs
netz so süß ich habe sogar noch von der
klausur kann man sich so noch mal drüber
ja
weil ich wollte jetzt netz über die form
das alles darüber wissen wegen der optik
dass man noch die schnecken optik hat
und deswegen kann man sich das auf den
teller machen und so richtig schön
darüber fließen lassen
oder leitung
das rezept nach machen alles
nachmachen wollt dann schaut vorbei oder
ich
[Musik]
wünsche euch viel spaß beim namen ihr
könnt ja gerne schreiben was euer
lieblings erdbeer rhabarber rezept ist
ob die schnecken oder was anderes er
war zwei super verkostung
gleich jedoch auf eine lanze für die
fotos dürfen nicht zu viel auf einmal
essen an das abba war
wichtig gut
das ist das was so
gesehen
[Gelächter]